cette semaine nous allons parler de
cinéma depuis votre canapé
les rendez vous hors champ vous propose
des ciné-débats des films et conférences
en ligne en partenariat avec des lieux
culturels yvelinois justin brasier
bonjour bonjour vous allez peut-être
nous présenter à ce projet d'avoir
exactement donc c'est un projet mené par
quatre étudiantes elles sont en master
management des organisations culturelles
et artistiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
donc elle propose comme vous nous l'avez
dit à des projections donc des
ciné-débats et l'événement a lieu sur
trois jours donc ce sera les 3 4 et 5
février
alors quel est le programme donc il y
aura trois projections de films et
documentaires ils seront sur le thème de
la musique
et comme il s'agit de ciné débat et bien
ils seront suivis d'une discussion en
live d'une heure environ et les films et
documentaires eux vont aussi durée 1h
1h30 environ
et je vous propose d'écouter justin
coullier qui est responsable du projet
hors champ et puis elle va nous
expliquer les films retenus on a le
professeur de violon qui aborde la
pédagogie et qui intéressait beaucoup la
clé puisqu'ils ont beaucoup d'ateliers
d'apprentissage culturel
on a un père claude jeanne qui est en
lien avec la musique et le handicap et
qui intéressait la batterie parce que
ils ont des projets à venir avec des
associations des fn qui s'occupe
justement de projets entre la musique et
handicap et enfin on a le documentaire
french lines sur la musique électronique
et alors quel est l'objectif de ces
rendez vous pendant la période actuelle
c'est surtout mettre en valeur les
structures et les associations
culturelles dans les yvelines qui reste
active malgré cette crise sanitaire là
notamment il y aura trois partenaires
donc la clé à saint-germain-en-laye la
batterie de guyancourt
et puis l'association met assauts de
voisins-le-bretonneux et donc c'est leur
redonner de la visibilité pour leur
donner l'occasion de
de parler avec leurs abonnés leurs
adhérents ou aussi de se faire connaître
par exemple de nouveaux étudiants qui
n'ont pas pu le découvrir ces structures
en arrivant par exemple pour faire leurs
études dans les yvelines
donc voilà leur donner une plateforme
pour discuter et pour parler de la
musique et de leurs projets passés ou
reporter qui arriveront quand ils
pourront réouvrir et comment fait-on
pour s'inscrire
alors pour participer il faut se rendre
sur le site de la 25e heure c'est en
fait une salle de cinéma virtuel qui
avait été créée face à la pandémie
justement de kobe de 19 avec notamment
la fermeture à des salles de cinéma est
donc là sur ce site vous pouvez réserver
vos places votre projection celle que
vous souhaitez et puis vous pouvez bien
sûr aussi passer par la page facebook
les rendez vous hors champ alors
attention les projections sont gratuites
mais le nombre de places est limité donc
je pense qu'il faudrait réserver l'avant
ce fou le conseil merci beaucoup justin